so as promised as we continue this road
to Deadpool kills Deadpool then as we go
over these different versions of
Deadpool what we do now is we jump to
the story of kid pool now while kid pool
has appeared in various comics as part
of Deadpool's continuity and what
prelude to the Deadpool Corps does is
give us the origin story of kid pool and
so this is the story that we're going to
focus on going forward into the Deadpool
kills Deadpool story
so as we get into our story what we do
here is we join Professor Charles Xavier
and storm at the Xavier orphanage for
troubled boys and what Xavier is doing
here as far as we can tell is he's
trying on different wigs and the reason
why is because Emma Frost is head of the
I guess the white queen school for girls
and they're going to be hosting a gala
at least Charles Xavier will be hosting
a gala that will involve Emma Frost and
her students attending Charles Xavier
school and what Charles Xavier is trying
to do is he's trying to get with them a
frost and so he's basically trying to
make sure he looks good well it happens
now what he tells storm is that he plans
on basically planting a subliminal
message in the mind of Emma Frost to
basically trick her into believing that
he's very attractive and that he's
always looked as good as he does in
order to basically hide his baldness
which seems to be something he's ashamed
of but what also happens here is that
storm tells Charles Xavier that the new
kid just isn't fitting in with everybody
else and that it may disrupt the gala
they plan on hosting and so what Charles
Xavier says while he's sporting a
dashing and incredibly amazing afro wig
as he says that storm needs to find the
first opportunity she can to basically
put Deadpool in detention and so what we
do here is we pick up with kid pool
while he's in class along with Scott
Summers and he's basically just being a
nuisance here he's giving Scott Summers
a hard time he's making fun of him he's
giving him a wedgie and so on and so
forth and being just Jenna generally
disruptive and so what happens if Scott
Summers complains to a Hank McCoy who's
the teacher and Hank McCoy sends both of
them to storms office and so once they
arrive in storms office what we find is
that Scott Summers immediately tells
storm waters has been going on that kid
pools been giving him a hard time and so
storm gives the both of them detention
now initially Scott Summers doesn't want
to go to detention in fact he begs storm
to let him stay out of detention
the reason being because Jean Grey is
going to be coming along with Emma Frost
as well as the other female students as
part of this gala that Scott Summer says
he loves her and so he wants to be there
when Jean Grey arrives but storms not
going to hear any of it and so what she
does is simply just again send up both
of them to detention so what we do here
is we jump to the danger room and the
danger room is basically the detention
location for any of the students who are
given detention the reason why as far as
it being explained to us is because with
as being the danger room there's really
nowhere they can go they're really just
kind of stuck in here but then Scott
Summers tells Deadpool that he has the
access code to get them out of there and
so what happens is initially Scott
Summers only wants to use the code in
order to make the time pass faster to
basically use the danger room so the two
of them can have a little bit of fun
here but really more or less just a way
to I guess again
take away from Deadpool probably giving
them a hard time and so what happens
here I think in one of the coolest
moments in the history of any of the
Deadpool comics is that kid pool finds
would appear to be a couple lifesavers
now think about this for a second
imagine like any variation of Deadpool
wielding lightsabers like how amazing
would that be and this is what happened
this kid pool apparently has a couple of
lightsabers and so kid pool and Scott
Summers start fighting one another and
for the most part the lightsabers are
knocked out of kid pools hands that he
can't cut Scott Summers in half and the
two of them start fighting but then all
of a sudden kid will stop Scott Summers
the reason being because in his mind he
can rationalize that if the two of them
are able to leave the danger room
because Scott Summers has the code then
they can go back to the ball and they
can basically start talking up different
women and so initially Scott Summer says
no he doesn't want to do this but
Deadpool where I guess kid pool begins
to basically change his mind by saying
that Wolverine is going to start talking
to Jean Grey and that Wolverine may very
well steal Jean Grey away from him and
so this manages to suede Scott Summers
and Scott Summers ends up letting the
two of them out and so what we do from
here is we join Charles Xavier as he's
macking on Emma Frost and doing a pretty
good job at it - I might add and it
seems as though he's been successful in
adding I guess implementing this
subliminal message in her mind because
that she suddenly finds him attractive
and I probably would too considering
that he's wearing this amazing blonde
wig that kind of makes him look like
longshot but he's kind of it looks like
it has like the bad-boy look without the
bad-boy attitude I don't really know how
to describe that but he looks pretty
awesome and so what we find is that
Wolverine is is basically talking with
Jean Grey and trying to a chat her up
and he's also sort of making fun of
Scott Summers and so we find the Scott
Summers and and kid pool or watching
this whole event take place and then
it's revealed to us that kid pool is
basically going to cause a distraction
here what kid pulls
says while he's brandishing both of
these lightsabers is that Scott Summers
needs to stay put and that kid pool is
going to cause a distraction by getting
the attention of everybody else
and so what he does here is he gets up
on the table and begins screaming at
everybody begins talking to everybody
and he actually addresses Emma Frost
school as the school for girls who keeps
her keep her legs crossed which is kind
of a adult reference here but
nonetheless the fact is that he begins
using his lightsabers to draw attention
and make a great big huge scene to kind
of poke fun at everybody and while this
is happening
Scott Summers steals Jean Grey away from
Wolverine and so what happens is that
the two of them start talking but we
also see that a lot of the other
students led by Wolverine begin to join
the fray and so suddenly as various
people begin attacking a Deadpool in
order to get him off the stage
Deadpool again continues to wreak havoc
here he continues to cause all kinds of
problems but then we find that Scott
Summers who makes his move with Jean
Grey and tries to tell her what it is
he's thinking ends up getting
friend-zoned so that sucks for Scott
Summers and then we find that Emma Frost
while she's talking with with Charles
Xavier we end up finding that Emma Frost
says that she initially intends to
basically go through and to I guess give
Charles Xavier a good time so to speak
but then suddenly storm busts in and
tells Charles Xavier that kid pool is
wreaking havoc in the ballroom and so
now Charles Xavier has basically been
blocked by kid pool and now he's in a
world of hurt and so basically at this
point everybody's mad at kid pool
because he's been screwing everybody
over and so while he's initially backed
into a corner while he's initially about
to be attacked by all these various
students storm of course shows up and so
this entire thing needs to come to an
end and then Charles Xavier arrives and
Charles Xavier says at at this point
there's really nothing they can do to
help kid pool but because because they
have money from the federal government
for a stimulus package that they have to
keep him here but as far as Charles
Xavier is concerned the most egregious
act that Deadpool's committed as he's
gotten in the way of Charles Xavier
getting with Emma Frost which in truth
is a legitimate claim like if Charles
Xavier actually had a chance to get with
Emma Frost and kid pool got in the way
I'd probably just lock him in a room and
never let him out but the fact remains
that kid pool is continuing to be made
fun of by everybody or buddy sort of
giving him a hard time
and so ultimately he says that if
everybody wants to believe that he's
going to leave but in the end it doesn't
really matter because he's going on to
bigger and better things but in truth
he's really just kind of bluffing here
he's really just kind of I guess trying
to maintain what little dignity he has
left but then suddenly we find the real
Deadpool from earth-616 shows up and
tells everybody that he has to take kid
pool away because kid pool needs to help
him to save the entire multiverse
basically telling everybody that they
suck because they're not as good as Kid
pool because they can't save the
multiverse which is awesome with that
being said that's pretty much the end of
this origin story that's where it stops
and so what we're gonna do is in the
next video I'm not sure who we're gonna
do maybe we will do mine pool maybe
we'll do Lady Deadpool I don't know look
at the different versions of Deadpool
and let me know who you guys want to see
in the next video with that being said I
will catch you guys later peace be sure
to follow me on Twitter there you can
keep up with all the updates from comics
explained and talk to me directly